[Applause]
[Music]
i remember the first time seeing his
name up there with dre juice taylor
swift in that top five in the world just
wasn't trying to be that jews just
became that he's making good music
when you were a fan of this [ __ ] you
look at from certain perspective but
then when you end this you see it for
what it really is i'm still happy i
could change the world but
it's not what it looked like
[Applause]
[Music]
he was so good at articulating his
feelings we ain't realized that's the
way he's feeling because it turned into
so much beautiful art it was hard to
separate the two
you know you tell you whoever that you
feel like you got anxiety it's like you
got depression they don't look at you
like you're crazy that's not how it
should be that's how it is and that
needs to change and hopefully i'm one of
those people that could bring that
change
sometimes it gets overwhelming but this
is what i ask for
i say certain things so i could have
conversations with my friends if people
get it and it relates to their life and
it's enough for them to get that [ __ ]
juice was a therapist for millions of
kids a voice of that generation
i want to say thank you and i love you
to all my supporters out there this is
your world you can do what i wouldn't
want to do
[Music]
you